first story we should talk about is
Boris subjective endless fascination and
he's managed to dominate the papers
again this weekend as well by saying
that Cameron should get serious about
Europe what do you think of it
well he's giving a speech on Wednesday
in which he'll say that Cameron needs to
be ready to leave the EU and give the
impression in his renegotiation he could
leave so over the past few years
whenever Cameron has talked about Europe
he said that he wants to stay in Europe
and whenever he's asked what he'd do if
his renegotiation would fail he said
well my renegotiation won't fail so I
don't need to think about that which is
quite a confident way of talking
particularly when you have angular
Merkel occasionally stitching you up
over things like john pogue Younker so
he can't actually be a certain as he
wants to be this is Boris just kind of
putting a marker down saying I'm a
little bit more robust than you Cameron
I'm still snapping at your heels you
think I'm gonna help you but actually on
my own man I'm I'm gonna make life
difficult for you if I wanted to as well
how irritated do you think that Cameron
will be but what I think to be fair to
Cameron he has shifted his language on
this recently anyway so when he came
back from his failure to block John Paul
Juncker even though he was fated in
Parliament as having stood up for the
right cause he also shifted his language
very slightly and he started to talk in
a conditional sense about staying in the
EU so he said if we get the changes that
we want I would be voting to stay in
well it's the first time I'd ever heard
him say it when he was talking about his
position in the referendum and I thought
that was quite significant that was
something that certainly cheered the
better off out here are skeptics who
want him you have that slightly more
robust position even if it's just a
little ride it and in other political
news as well this week what do you
think's looming on the horizon
Miliband well I think the battle over
foreign policy in the way the government
is responding to the increasingly
febrile international situation isn't
going to go away nor all the other
announcements from Labour about welfare
and all the sort of discussion about you
to insignificance compared to what's
going on in Israel and Miliband's
intervention over the weekend he's
previously condemned what Israel was
doing but he's now saying why isn't the
government condemning what is fair
listing why isn't David Cameron being
stronger in his language and that was
what Downing Street really resented was
it wasn't just Miliband
standing up for he thought was happening
but actually it was Miliband saying you
guys aren't taking a strong enough line
and they accused him of playing politics
and Chris Grayling as she accused him of
endangering the international situation
with his words which is perhaps quite
complimentary for the Labour leader
because he is only the lane leader of
the Opposition yeah yes
that's all the grading comments work
there were bitter and overreaction I
mean I cannot believe that either Hamas
or the Israeli government is saying
whatever Miliband has done or said
indeed with one the weirdest
interjection so find the whole Gaza
debate was at Miliband saying at an
early stage when there were air at their
operations but ground troops have gone
in that he thought it would be unwise
the same ground troops in I mean I no
one knows when Ed Miller man last won a
war or directed an army or studied
military strategy even and very odd for
someone in that position from any
political party abroad to be giving
advice like that but in any case Ed
Miliband's you know desire to intervene
in this is I think understandable I
don't agree with it but it's
understandable because he obviously a
members of his party's parliamentary
party are I think you know coming under
quite a lot of pressure from
constituents on this mm-hmm
a lot of Labour MPs say you know the
number one thing in their postback even
when there's not a flare-up like there
is at the moment between Israel and Gaza
that they say that their post bags are
filled with letters about this issue and
you know if the Labour Party really this
is this is something at the grassroots
they they feel